bruno le maire est l'invité de preuves
par 3 bonsoir merci d'être avec nous ex
futur candidat à la présidence de l'ump
resterez-vous non-alignés jusqu'au bout
alors que françois fillon et jean
françois copé dévoilent leurs programmes
pour leur parti mais aussi pour votre
parti c'est le vôtre également également
pour la france frédéric dumoulin de l'
agence france-presse vous interrogera
dans un quart d'heure sur cette question
donc dans la seconde partie de
l'émission avec perrine tarneaud de
public sénat ensuite nous verrons où
vous établissez la balance entre l'homme
politique et l'écrivain à chaque fois
d'ailleurs de plus en plus attendus la
première édition de votre premier roman
musique absolue c'est gallimard est
épuisé un beau succès les
téléspectateurs peuvent réagir
durant cette émission par le biais de
l'application tivi tchèque de notre
partenaire orange d'abord bruno le maire
françois hollande méthyle c'est pas dans
ceux de nicolas sarkozy la question est
posée non seulement au sujet du traité
budgétaire européen s'est défendue par
l'exécutif avec la même fougue que
nicolas sarkozy qu'il avait négocié la
question est posée également après la
visite surprise du chef de l'état à
echirolles où s'est déroulé un acte de
barbarie ayant conduit à la mort de deux
jeunes gens sans histoire alors est ce
qu il met ses pas dans ceux de son
prédécesseur dans le style tout ce que
je souhaite en tout cas c'est qu'ils
obtiennent des résultats sur les sujets
vous avez cité que ce choix ge sur la
question européenne interviendra et
surtout sur la question de la sécurité
parce qu'on voit bien dans certains
quartiers il drame d'echirolles me
rappelle que ce sont devenus des zones
de non droit des zones de violence
absolue où on n'arrive plus à contenir
les comportements de certains et donc je
crois qu'il ya une urgence absolue à
rétablir la sécurité à appliquer des
sanctions exemplaires sur les
responsables des deux crimes qui ont été
commis
et puis de voir ensuite comment est-ce
qu'on peut sortir de cette situation
comment est-ce qu'on peut rétablir la
paix le calme le sens du civisme dans un
certain nombre de quartiers là on est
face à un acte de barbarie devant lequel
on est tous des murs
tous une bande de jeunes je pense que
ces riverains lynchage une question qui
est posée à la société française toute
entière ne pensons pas une seconde qu'il
suffira que la police la justice fasse
bien leur travail et je souhaite
évidemment qu'elles fassent bien au
travail pour que ça permette de rétablir
le calme et la sérénité dans un certain
nombre de zones en france je pense que
nous avons tous une responsabilité pour
établir le sens du civisme en france
qu'on doit bien comprendre que ça
commence dans les familles ça commence
dans l'éducation par le père et par la
mer ça commence par le travail à l'école
ça commence par le rôle de chaque
citoyen c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à
prendre vraiment en main le
rétablissement de la sécurité en france
il faut bien entendu des sanctions
exemplaires
il faut bien entendu une chaîne pénale
qui fonctionne bien entre police et
justice
et chacun d'entre nous doit se sentir
interpellés parce que l'on gagne raison
manuel valls de parler de massacre dans
ce cas précis ce qui s'est passé au
début de week-end à echirolles en tout
cas c'est un acte d'une violence inouïe
d'une violence inouïe
tous les détails qui ont été données
utilisation des couteaux de la batte de
baseball du marteau enfin tout ça laisse
totalement pantois bon je vais avancer
sur la question de la sécurité il est
crédité
moi ce que je crois en la matière que il
a un discours de fermeté ni bhl convient
ce que je sais simplement c'est que sur
la sécurité
vous ne gagnez qu'avec la mobilisation
de tous à la fois la chaîne pénale
sécurité justice et il faut que le
christine taubira change un peu
d'orientation et de choix en matière de
justice
vous pouvez pas supprimer les peines
planchers alléger les peines sont les
récidivistes
il dira qu en même temps vous êtes pour
le renforcement la sécurité j'ai bien
peur que tout le travail de manuel valls
ce soit de l'eau dans du sable parce que
de l'autre côté son hub de la justice
elle au lieu de renforcer les peines les
allèges on n'ait pas répondu sur les
similitudes entre l'attitude de françois
hollande
hier soir et puis c'est l'on s'en
souvient de nicolas sarkozy sur la dalle
d'argenteuil un qui est interpellé par
des habitants chaque président son style
sa chance à andy dans son orientation se
ressemblent ce que je trouve c'est que
il ya eu une dégelée de critiques
invraisemblable contre nicolas sarkozy
pendant la campagne présidentielle
il a été accablé de reproches tout ceci
est injuste et un que les autres et ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'ensuite françois
hollande vient penaud faire exactement
la même chose que nicolas sarkozy
l'avait cité l'exemple du déplacement
sur la sécurité pourrait aussi citer
l'exemple du traité européen où il
n'avait en général et du rhume sur
lignon roi fait un nom peu d'eau parce
que je vois bien que sur le traité sur
l'union européenne
on peut pas dire que les socialistes
soient très flambant il voit bien que
tout ça est un peu bancal qu'ils avaient
les produits des choses et qu'ils ont
pas pu les tenir qu'il avait dit sur la
renault 4l match à mort on va renégocier
le traité européen et puis finalement
dans le texte les vues avant l'élection
présidentielle
je les ai relu après l'élection
présidentielle n'est pas une jungle de
change
d'accord milieu des ajouts sur la
croissance c'est ce que fait valoir le
premier ministre
les ajouts sur la croissance mais
j'aimerais qu'on s'arrête un instant là
dessus d'abord ils n'ont pas la même
valeur juridique
ensuite ce sont de pures engagement de
principe on va débloquer 120 milliards
d'euros on sait pas très bien pourquoi
pour quel projet tout ça j'ai peur là
encore que ça se solde par beaucoup de
déception
la croissance en europe a sera pas
relancé par 120 milliards d'euros
débloquée ici ou là ne sera relancé par
des décisions collectives en matière de
gouvernance économique en matière de
choix industriels et matière
d'innovation et de recherche et de lutte
contre l'endettement et les déficits
évidemment on va en parler bruno le
maire mais c'est une priorité aux jambes
penaud dites vous est ce que vous êtes
mis qu'il est trop absents sachant que
c'est son premier ministre qui monte au
créneau notamment à l'assemblée
nationale et au sénat bien sûr pour
essayer de réunir le plus de suffrages
sur ce triste ce traité c'est à eux
d'établir qui doit être en première
ligne en deuxième ligne
moi ce que je constate simplement c'est
que le gouvernement fait fausse route
et comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
l'assemblée il met la france où droit
dans le mur
les choix sont pas les bons on
connaissait la réponse elle devait les
venues de jérôme cahuzac dans le mur
mais c'est systématiquement la même
ritournelle est ce qu'on croyait que
jusqu'à 2017 en mentant de sacs
ritournelle de sciences et planter c'est
la faute de la droite mais c'est pas la
solution et adc le havre s'en servir
tous les pouvoirs croissants ils ont
toutes les responsabilités
donc c'est à eux de rendre des comptes
aux français et plus le temps va avancer
- françois hollande - jean-marc ayrault
pourront invoquer les erreurs du
précédent gouvernement pour expliquer
l'échec de leur politique
ils promettent 0 2% de croissance les
prochaines et 2% sur les années
suivantes
je sais pas prendre mon pari c'est pas
qu'ils espèrent c'est que c'est inscrit
dans les doigts finances qui sont votées
par les parlementaires il n'est pas un
texte unique de jaillir cette séance
chaque est inscrit dans les textes votés
par les représentants du peuple français
et bien moi je vous dis ce soir que ses
oreilles de lui pour cent et ses deux
fois 2 % ne seront pas tenues et ça sera
à mettre au débit du gouvernement comme
un des mensonges supplémentaire de ce
gouvernement il a menti ce traité
européen
y'a pas une renégociation il a menti sur
les gens pour on va arrêter les
fermetures d usines on veut empêcher la
fermeture d'aulnay ils n'y sont pas
arrivés
et maintenant ils nous promettent 0,8
pour cent de croissance et les
prochaines 2% les deux années suivantes
eh bien je suis prêt à prendre tous les
paris que ces chiffres là ne seront pas
tenues et que ce sera à mettre à nouveau
au débit du moulin dans quoi à cause de
vous pouvez pas éteindre un moteur de la
croissance qui est la consommation en
augmentant massivement les impôts de
tous les ménages français sans allumer
un autre moteur qui suit la
compétitivité ils n'ont pas allumé le
moteur de la compétition ça va venir en
aide aux migrants comme philippe varin
le patron de psa des abeilles à une
bonne nouvelle qu'un à l'horizon on va
aborder la question de la compétitivité
on attend le rapport de louis gallois
vous savez en 2013 on l'a fait en 2004 à
1013 me jurez skills a annoncé urgentes
doivent être prises tout de suite et par
ailleurs ils se sont fermées à septembre
deux portes ils me font dire on a éteint
le moteur de la consommation et on n'a
pas allumé le moteur des entreprises et
la même activité avait commencé et
franchement sur les impôts et on sait
bien que la droite et la gauche sont à
égalité se rassure en changeant juste un
logiciel
c'est ce pourquoi je plaide dans la
campagne pour le renouveau de la droite
républicaine changeant de look
ici elle notre logiciel n'est plus
adapté à la réalité économique française
par ailleurs ce gouvernement c'est
fermer des portes quand il dit on
augmentera ni la csg ni la tva et en
même temps d'améliorer la compétitivité
des entreprises françaises comment est
ce qu'ils vont faire pour faire baisser
le coût du travail qui est un des
problèmes clés la compétitivité
française
si vous augmentez ni la csg ni la tva
en tous les cas là franchement c'est une
émotion qui me paraît difficile à lille
mais peut-être qu'il faut patienter
encore quelques mois en arrière dès 2013
moi je suis en parlera de la tradition
quand j'ai lancé la bataille sociale
français le traité budgétaire européen
jean marc ayrault est ce qu il a raison
de dramatiser l'enjeu
oui moi je suis pas pour une opposition
caricaturale
quand il reçoit jeudi qu'il vendrait
sauver l'euro il a raison oui il a
raison il a raison et je ne suis pas
pour une opposition caricaturale
je dis ce que j'ai à dire ce
gouvernement mais économiquement la
france dans le mur
mais quand jean marc ayrault dit que
c'est un enjeu majeur et que c'est
l'avenir de l'euro qui est en jeu il a
raison et j'espère que tous les
socialistes sauront faire preuve de sens
des responsabilités en bateau voter ce
traité moi je suis plus à l'ump donc de
voir que dans un gouvernement où nous ne
sommes pas au pouvoir n'a pas les mêmes
responsabilités moi c'est la première
fois que je vois dans l'histoire la vème
république un gouvernement dont certains
membres vont voter un traité jugé
essentiel par le prêt ministres et
d'autres alors même que le prémunissent
leur a dit le matin c'est essentiel
c'est vital c'est l'avenir de l'euro est
en jeu et ne voteront pas qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont encore à faire dans ce
gouvernement
ils se sentent bien être encore dans un
gouvernement dont le premier ministre a
dit voter ce texte c'est essentiel non
nous le vote pas sûr que ça pose un
problème de déontologie europe ecologie
les verts donc associé au gouvernement
estime que ce traité en fait n'est pas
crucial pour le sauvetage de la zone
euro c'est une autre lecture
manifestement oui mais c'était une
mauvaise lecture
en tous les cas jean marc ayrault
demande une approbation global de
l'orientation européenne du gouvernement
ils le demandent à toutes les
composantes de la majorité avant vous
rentrez que vous assure vous allez voter
oui vous l'avez rappelé donc ça vaudra
de votre part approbation au global de
l'orientation européenne du gouvernement
mais à non non parce que il faut bien
comprendre que ce traité budgétaire
européen c'est simplement un point de
départ c'est fait pour remettre de la
discipline au sein de la zone euro
et moi je suis favorable à cette
discipline au sein de la zone euro parce
que je suis lassé de voir qu'il ya des
petits malins qui continuent à dépenser
l'argent des autres tandis que les eaux
sont objet faire des économies pour
rembourser les dettes des voisins je
pense que ça ne peut pas continuer comme
ça et se traite et budgétaire une chose
très simple on et 17
il faut qu'on ait tous la même
discipline il faut que ces disciplines
choix contrôle et donc je le vote dès
demain ensuite on a besoin de changer de
cap en europe
et ce changement de cap je ne le vois
pas porté par l'engagement avec un
nouveau traité plus générale il faut une
réforme des institutions et en
profondeur pour avoir plus de clarté
plus de visibilité plus de démocratie
la commission européenne qui va avoir du
pouvoir sur les budgets européens
moi je souhaite que cette commission
européenne soit composé de membres élus
et plus de membres nommés que chaque
commissaire soient issus par exemple
avec le parlement européen pour qu'il
ait une légitimité comme les transferts
de souveraineté éventuelle ne vous
effraie pas vous les acceptez si
l'europe 6 aussi les plus démocratiques
et plus démocratique et chant l'accueil
l'orientation économique pour défendre
ses intérêts c'est encore ces
entreprises et pas ceux des grandes
puissances voisines alors on connaît
l'opposition de gauche au traité vous
l'avez rappelé évidemment mais il ya des
partisans de ce texte au parti
socialiste qui s'interrogent néanmoins
sur la pertinence des 3% de déficit
est ce que c'est une question qui ne
doit pas être tabou comme le dit harlem
désir est ce que son pourrait reporter
d'un an par exemple cet objectif c'est
on n'a pas arrêté au cours des décennies
passées de chercher des prétextes pour
ne pas respecter ses engagements
parallèles à la crise j'avais 6 ans en
mai verte et ou mal portée on sentait
mal portée moi je souhaite qu'on s'en
tienne à cette réduction des déficits et
à cette obligation les 3% et qu'on
consacre le temps disponible aux débats
allaient changer les autres pays
européens sur la réorientation de
l'europe une europe qui arrêtent avec
son principe de libre échange absolu
une europe qui arrêtent de faire la
concurrence libre et absolue l'alpha et
l'oméga de toutes ces décisions
économiques
une europe qui devrait politique
industrielle innovante de
l'harmonisation sociale accord est il
le convergeaient ce procès alors pour le
reste programme le premier ministre
réaffirme que le traité européen
n'entendra pas la souveraineté de la
france vous êtes là également d'accord
bruno le maire c'est un peu une réponse
aussi une partie de la droite de la
droite populaire par exemple soyons
arrivés très pragmatique pas d'idéologie
là dedans mais qu'est ce qui menace
aujourd'hui la souveraineté des états
européens l'espagne la grèce l'italie ou
peut-être un jour la france
mais merci quand ça europe à laquelle
nous participons à laquelle nous avons
notre voie c'est des marchés financiers
si vous êtes endettés c'est vos
créanciers qui vous donnent des ordres
et c'est eux qui prennent le pouvoir
regarder ce qui est en train de se
passer à florange qui donne les
instructions à l'état français par son
action mittal qui dit l état français
vous avez 60 jours pour trouver un
repreneur à coucher heureux oui ça me
choque c'est un ultimatum
ça me choque ça sonne comme un ultimatum
est ce que la france de retrouver sa
pleine souveraineté économique et
financière oui ou non si on veut le
faire il faut réduire les déficits
grâce à ce traité européen et retrouver
de la force économique grâce à des
efforts de compétitivité c'est ça la
souveraineté alors on a vu que vous êtes
une force de proposition on va voir
maintenant quel type d'opposition doit
selon vous incarnez l'ump bruno le maire
c'est l'une des questions qui est posée
bien sûr dans cette course à la
présidence où vous avez déclaré forfait
la compétition ramener au duel fillon
copé inquiète une partie des
parlementaires
ce qui ne les empêche pas de se
positionner à un an va en parler dans un
instant avec vous et avec réveil du
moulin de là explique d'abord c'est
reportage de mathilde de bélanger
elle devait être placée sous le signe du
rassemblement pourtant jeudi dernier
c'est bien le duel fillon copé qui a
dominé les journées parlementaires de
l'ump à marcq en baroeul
au point d'exaspérer certains
parlementaires non-alignés s'ils
pouvaient se calmer un peu et arrêter
les pitres à ça ferait du bien à tout le
monde fait dans mes permanences en
circonscription j'entends pas grand me
dire qui va gagner l'ump
j'entends tout le monde me dire mais
qu'est ce qu'ils foutent en eau est ce
qu'ils ont pas autre chose qu'à se
préoccuper de 2017
copé qui joue la carte de l'extrême
droite d'un côté fillon et son manque de
courage de l'autre les petites phrases
fusent entre les partisans des deux
candidats au risque de rendre inaudibles
le message de l'opposition et une
confusion des genres que regrette
bernard acoyer le rôle de nous autres
parlementaires le rôle de nos groupes
parlementaires dans l'opposition chez de
travailler sur le fond sur la situation
sur les idées sur les propositions et 7
7 10 ans si l'on peut dire entre les
groupes parlementaires et le mouvement
politique a toujours été une exigence et
je souhaiterais que nous la gardien au
sénat l'affrontement restent feutrées et
on l'a sur il n'y a aucune conséquence
sur l'entente au sein du groupe
un sénat d'ailleurs plus largement
fillonniste 71 sénateurs ump se sont
déjà prononcés en faveur de l'ancien
premier ministre contre 28 pour jean
françois copé il faut pas manier la
langue de bois aujourd'hui la campagne
pour le président de l'ump
c'est le premier round et je pense qu'il
sera décisif de la campagne pour
l'investiture présidentielle de deux
buts et ça c'est aussi d'ailleurs une
des raisons pour lesquelles le sénat est
beaucoup plus largement derrière
françois fillon c'est que le sénat
estime que dans sa majorité que ce
candidat est plus consensuelle et moins
clivant
reste à savoir si l'élection de novembre
désignera un vrai leader au parti ou si
la guerre des chefs se poursuivra
jusqu'aux primaires de 2016 l'ombre de
nicolas sarkozy plane toujours sur cette
échéance pour beaucoup il est le seul
capable de rassembler
voilà nicolas sarkozy avec qui vous avez
toujours des contacts vous allez pouvoir
nous en dire un peu plus j'espère que
cet instant avec frédéric dumoulin qui
nous a rejoint notre confrère de
l'agencé france presse et qui suivent de
très près cette compétition donc on est
à monsieur le maire on est à sept
semaines de l'élection du président de
l'ump
donc on voit les sondages les soutiens
est ce que vous faites partie 2 comme
certains qu'on a vu dans ce reportage de
ceux qui pense en fait que les jeux sont
faits et que françois fillon un vraiment
un net avantage sur jean françois copé
dont je pense pas je pense qu'une
élection ce n'est jamais jouée jusqu'au
dernier moment c'est les militants qui
trancheront
on a deux profils qui sont très
différents ça montre qu'on est capable
d'avoir la complémentarité
à l'ump c'est à dire vous avez un profil
qui est effectivement plus consensuel
profil quelqu'un qui est ancien poids
ministre vous avez un profil plus
combattant quelqu'un qui était
secrétaire général de l'ump et que c'est
pas les mêmes leur fils a stipulé le
mieux aux militants justement allo c'est
moi j'habite en normandie et en
normandie est de générer pratique corner
s il inscrivait sa peine il rentre mais
c'est parce que je suis certain que
c'est ce que je vois dans ma
circonscription
vous avez certains militants qui sont
très sensibles au caractère plus
combatif de jean françois copé d'autres
qui sont beaucoup plus sensibles à
l'aspect rassembleur de françois et cg
vous maîtrisez raciale difficile de dire
qui va l'emporter à la fin très
difficile mais chez vous dans votre
exemple partis et de leurs donc vous
dirais qu'avant tâche qui attend l'heure
ils votent pour bruno le maire vous
savez qui reste en liberté
je leur laisse leur totale liberté c'est
aux militants de trancher on n'est pas
dans la situation du choix du candidat à
l'élection présidentielle
on n'est pas dans une primaire ou ceux
qui s'engagent c'est l'avenir de la
france où la essentiellement fillon il
faut faire un choix il faut trancher il
faut afficher son choix là on est dans
le choix et président de l'ump
donc je crois que tout ce qui permet
d'éviter les divisions et tout ce qui
permet aussi de penser à l'après 18
novembre quand il faudra se rassembler
quand il faudra se retrouver c'est utile
et moi c'est à ça que je pouvais leur
mode d'hébergement vous n'êtes pas
candidat
je n'ai pas pu l'être candidat à la
présidence de l'ump vous avez dit que
vous ne choisit riez pas c'est ce ce non
alignement vous allez garder jusqu'au
bout
je voulais un alignement moi je n'aime
pas tellement ce terme là qui donne le
sentiment qu'on se mouiller pour rien
moi je trouve que pendant plusieurs
semaines
j'ai mené un combat pour le renouveau de
la droite et je reste persuadé que ce
renouveau de la droite est indispensable
pour gagner les élections de 2014
je suis parti en juillet j'avais pas de
militants derrière moi je n'ai pas de
parlementaires j'ai fini à la fin du
mois de septembre avec plus de 8000
signatures un peu trop tard
malheureusement et une trentaine de
parlementaires
ces gens là il croit au renouveau moi je
veux continuer à le porter mais j'ai
tous ceux qui penchent sur l'élection
des gens doués je vais me taire en
seront pour leurs frais vous disiez je
continuerai à parler à m'exprimer à
défendre mes convictions
vous disiez la fin de l'été que vous ne
voyez pas chez les autres de véritables
projets donc maintenant on avec françois
fillon avait proposé son pacte pour la
france et d'un autre côté on à monsieur
copé qui présente le manifeste pour une
droite décomplexée
est ce que vous vous y voyez un réel
projet est ce que ça vous satisfait
qu'elle quelles sont les différences qui
portent ferrique dumoulin le non cumul
des mandats qui porte la limitation à
trois du nombre de mandats nationaux
successifs pour essayer d'avoir un peu
de cohérence par rapport à la limitation
à deux des mandats présidentiels qui
porte la réduction du nombre de
sénateurs à 250 et du nombre de
parlementaires a comme 150 personnes là
vous avez converti personnes là dessus
non mais c'est des choses auxquelles je
crois
et moi ma conviction forte c'est que
l'ump ne retrouvera le dialogue avec les
français que si elle est capable
dans ses orientations politiques dans sa
pratique politique de changer et c'est
pour ça que je veux continuer à porter
ce mal sans vous il n'y a pas d'avenir
pour l'ump alors non ce n'est pas ça du
tout on a besoin vous avez différentes
d'une loi de renouveau et s'est engagé à
se prononcer très lui dans le n'importe
lequel je voterai comme n'importe quel
militant de l'ump
mais je vais vous qu'il n'allait pas
part de mon vote parce que je crois que
c'est mieux comme cela mais vous avez
déjà listé pour qui vous allez voter
sans le dire forcément je n'ai pas
encore décidé et donc ramené pas encore
décédé
qu'est ce que vous attendez mais on
comprend déjà temps et avoir un débat il
va y avoir la présentation plus globale
des projets des uns et des autres je
suis comme n'importe quel militant je
regarde attentivement
10 chacun des candidats chacun à son
talent chacun a ses qualités et je crois
que ce sera très important jusqu'au
dernier moment de voir exactement ce
qu'il propose non seulement comme projet
pour la france c'est un aspect important
effectivement l'élection mais aussi
comme projet pour lui une fois que vous
seriez l'organisation quel
fonctionnement est ce qu'on veut des
courants ont pas de courant mais une
facette vous ne le dirait pas non non
non je crois que les militants qui me
soutiennent les parlementaires qui me
soutiennent en droit à garder leur
totale liberté et ils n'ont pas besoin
de consignes de vote de ma part donc
vous ne serez pas comme françois baroin
à un autre de vos amis qui a pris fait
et cause pour monsieur fillon récemment
et on voit que vous étiez donc dans la
même dans des mousquetaires qu'on a pu
la bande des mousquetaires jusqu'à il ya
peu
donc valérie pécresse et françois baroin
ont pris fait et cause pour monsieur
fillon monsieur jacob et monsieur chatel
sont allés vers monsieur copé et
vous-même donc vous êtes neutre on va
dire les mousquetaires se retourner
chacun dans leur foyer je pense que ça
n'a échappé à personne
nous avons à livrer des combats
collectifs qui je trouve étaient
intéressants étaient utiles je pense que
ce qu'on a dit sur la gouvernance sur le
fonctionnement du gouvernement étaient
des choses qui étaient intéressantes au
moment les hadiths c'est-à-dire deux ans
pour l'élection présidentielle de 2012
maintenant chacun reprend sa liberté il
est ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on en
fasse pas un drame non il n'existe plus
n'existe plus chacun a repris sa liberté
certains ont fait le choix de soutenir
un candidat c'est le cas de valérie
pécresse le cas de françois bayrou à moi
je respecte parfaitement le choix de
chacun luc chatel lui s'est rangé aux
côtés de jean françois copé
là aussi c'est parfaitement légitime et
moi j'essaye de construire ma propre
voie qui est celle du renouveau
politique à l'ump vous êtes d'accord
vous c'est dormoy qui dit qu'en fait
c'est pas l'amitié qui doit guider quoi
que ce soit et donc lui a fait le choix
de monsieur fillon quel que soit son
amitié pour monsieur copé est ce que
vous trouvez que c'est compliqué de
garder l'amitié en politique ou pas oui
je pense jamais fait ça a cliqué mais
l'amitié ça compte
oui c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
les balayer comme ça d'un revers de main
vous avez tout à leur premier essai des
paroles sur l'europe
vous êtes un européen convaincu est ce
que il n'ya pas une certaine crispation
identitaire qui vous gêne aujourd'hui à
l'ump quand on entend l'un de vos amis
votre ami
jean françois copé parler de racisme
anti blanc est-ce que je crois que c'est
pas la question de ce qu'a dit jean
françois sur le racisme anti blanc ou
une phrase ou une autre qui peut être
prononcée par lui ou pour un autre c'est
la grande question de savoir si l'ump se
rétrécit ou si l'ump s'élargit et
capable de convaincre une majorité de
français moi je lutterai de toutes mes
forces contre le rétrécissement de l'ump
je pense que l'ump qui n'est pas capable
de forger sa propre doctrine l'ump qui
n'a pas sa propre idéologie ump qui
n'est pas capable de défendre ses
propres propositions ne convaincra pas
les frais si je remplace le mot
rétrécissement par droitisation c'est la
même idée c'est pas la même idée sympa
la même idée droitisation moi je sais
pas très bien ce que ça veut dire
honnêtement et des attentes de la part
des français sur la nation sur le
communautarisme
il ya des attentes sur le respect des
principes républicains qui sont
essentiels et reprendra votre compte
l'expression racisme anti blanc ce que
je sais c'est que sur ce sujet il ya une
société française qui est en train de se
communautariser et que le
communautarisme n'est pas compatible
avec la nation française et par
conséquent tout ce qui peut lutter
contre le communautarisme va dans le bon
sens tout ce qui permet de renforcer la
nation va dans le bon sens vous parlez
d'un rétrécissement de l'ump mais c'est
le rétrécissement c'est que c'est un
petit peu aussi une critique en creux de
l'action de l'ancien président le
rétrécissement c'est quoi c'est oublier
que il ya des jeunes qui attendent
beaucoup de nous qu'ils attendent un
espoir un espoir européen espoir
national qui nous disent mais dit des
choses positives sur notre capacité à
créer sur une volonté d'entreprendre sur
la formation professionnelle
le rétrécissement c'est éviter d'oublier
que il y à des pays européens qui attend
de la france qu'elle s'exprime sur un
certain nombre de sujets le
rétrécissement c'est oublier que il y a
des gens qui sont dans la difficulté est
systématiquement pointer du doigt les
uns ou les autres ça se rétrécissent
mans là il nous conduira à l'échec
ça ne veut pas dire très précisément uma
thurman mais le rétrécissement c'est le
risque
après la défaite voilà on n'est pas la
question ils datent pas du moins le
rétrécissement s'est il a mené les
essais à l'échelle des fêtes c'est de se
dire bon maintenant le fond il faut
rester dans leur pré carré le plus
étroit oublier qu'il ya des millions de
français qui attendent notre part un
message fort sur le dynamisme économique
sur l'entrepreneuriat sur la place
d'informations professionnelles sur
l'europe
on sait ce message là que je porte et je
pense que face
échec de la gauche face à une gauche qui
n'a pas d'autre idée que taxer toujours
plus et de ruiner l'esprit d'entreprise
dans ce pays nous nous devons être ceux
qui créent un espoir est que pensez vous
de l'idée de jean françois copé de
transformer le mp en espèces deux
parties de services pour les victimes
comme allemand des cours du soir et
autres moi je pense que avoir défrayé
sur aider tous ceux qui sont dans
l'opposition pas très concret tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont dans les
oppositions dans les petites communes
dans les communes moyennes qui ont
besoin de formation que blain de soutien
de l'ump
oui ça je pense que ça va dans le bon
sens que c'est indispensable
le travail pour gagner en 2014 on va pas
de commencer comme on le fait d'habitude
fin 2013 on en janvier 2014
c'est maintenant qu'il faut le commencer
repérer les équipes formées les gens
aider les gens organiser des réunions
politiques avant un contact avec les
associations penser la politique
différemment pour convaincre les
électeurs en 2014 c'est ça qui me paraît
plus important mais vous ne pouvez pas
nés quand même vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure pourtant que celui qui sera élu
président de l'ump aura un avantage pour
la primaire en vue de la présidentielle
edouard balladur laissez moi ça me pose
pas de problème ou de considérer qu'on
prend un avantage pour ça et c'est pour
cela la seule chose c'est que je pense
que ça n'intéresse aucun français mais
aucun le gagnant ni les militants appuie
les symphatisants ni ceux qui sont nos
opposants très bien beaucoup de monde
qui s'intéresse pas du tout du tout à
cette élection de 2010 est pourquoi
parce que d'abord il ya une étape qui
2014 et contrairement à beaucoup je ne
crois pas à la victoire mécanique de la
droite
en 2014 on gagnera sur un projet si on a
formé les opposants et si on est capable
d'avoir de bons candidats dans toutes
les villes de france
la deuxième chose que moi je n'oublie
jamais dans mon engagement politique
c'est que ce que je vois sur le terrain
c'est pas des gens qui me disent mais
alors qui va l'emporter à l'ump qui va
être candidat à la présidentielle ou à
la primaire c'est des gens qui me disent
on est pardonnez moi l'expression dans
une merde noire
on n'a pas d'emploi on sait pas ce que
vont devenir nos enfants on n'a pas de
formation
on est au chômage on était mécanicien on
était couvreur on était fraser et on est
dans des endroits où il ya plus aucune
de ces entreprises
et quand on va au chômage on n'est pas
fort mais parce qu'il ya que 10 % des
chômeurs qui sont formés en france il
n'y a pas d'avenir industrielle il ya un
marasme économique sans précédent et
c'est sans doute là dessus
on sent pas décourager par peut-être
l'absence de pouvoir des politiques
aujourd'hui et certains ouvriers de
florange le dit bien sûr vous l'avez
dans des lieux à montréjeau csm est en
train de se développer aujourd'hui en
france c'est un sentiment d'impuissance
complète des responsables politiques et
moi c'est à ça que je veux répondre si
vous voulez éviter ce sentiment
d'impuissance complète et responsables
politiques la première chose à faire
c'est de dire la vérité la vérité quand
vous avez un ministre du redressement
productif qui va voir les salariés les
ouvriers qui leur dit avec moi y aura
pas de fermetures d'usinés et que toutes
les usines fermer une à mal et j'ai
entendu sarnez est conférée
politiquement et bien changeant aussi là
dessus mais changent aussi là dessus
y compris à droite revenons une seconde
sur le gameplay on a beaucoup parlé de
jean françois copé de françois fillon
et on n'a pas encore parlé de celui qui
est un petit peu le fantôme cette
élection c'est bien nicolas sarkozy est
ce que vous croyez un retour de nicolas
sarkozy à ce que je crois c'est que il
suit attentivement ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en france il voulait ce qui
est normal comme pour un ancien
président de la république qui est
inquiet de la situation économique et de
l'effondrement du pays
donc il suit cela attentivement ce que
j'ai constaté aussi c'est que c'est un
homme en pleine forme c'est un homme
très déterminé et qu'ensuite la décision
de revenir ou de ne pas revenir lui
appartient totalement totalement
il trouve que la compétition devant elle
et il vous a fait des commentaires sur
le niveau de venant de la bataille de
à présent de l'ump non mais comme je
vous dis ce qui l'inquiète c'est ce qui
me préoccupe c'est plus la situation de
la france que ce qui se passe assez cher
et si jamais il décide de revenir à ce
que vous pouvez est-ce que vous pensez
que monsieur copé que monsieur fillon le
laisserai revenir pleinement dans le jeu
moi je n'ai pas changé d'avis sur ce
sujet là je pense que je suis nicolas
sarkozy revient et bien les autres quels
qu'ils soient et quels que soient leur
talent et leur capacité laisseront la
place à nicolas sarkozy personne ne
pourra s'y opposer
je pense sera difficile surtout qu'il
est déterminé ni voilà dix ans sait pas
trop à quoi je voudrais d'état nommé
j'étais remis ça ce en général merci
frédéric van a parlé de vous désormais
bruno le maire ou avec vous ne se résume
pas à aborder la question européenne
celle des sujets de l'économie ou de
l'avenir de l'ump mais également il ya
le volet littéraire qui est donc
authentifié par le label gallimard qui
publie votre premier roman musique
absolue perrine tarneaud vous à lui nous
rejoint dans un instant après un détour
rue sébastien bottin
reportage à suivre tout de suite à
l'entrée de la maison gallimard où l'on
croise philippe djian comme on croisera
un collègue
le premier roman de bruno le maire
musique absolue trône sur l'étagère de
la très prestigieuse collection blanche
l'ancien ministre de l'agriculture est
seulement le deuxième politique
après dominique de villepin à y être
accepté signe qu'il appartient désormais
à la famille des écrivains bruno le
maire fait partie de ces gens qui ont
une attention très importante pour le
style
ils ont une manière d'écrire qui n'est
pas celle du tout venant et qui fait de
leur de leurs livres quelque chose qui
va bien au delà d'une intervention ou
d'un témoignage politique
normalien reçu premier à l'agrégation de
lettres modernes
bruno le maire
à aimer les lettres avant la politique
mais juge les deux indissociables la
politique sans la littérature devient
une petite une petite chose qui se
croient importante mais qui ne l'est
plus parce qu'elle a au fond elle n'a
pas de deux considérations réel pour la
puissance de la parole
si tous les hommes politiques de premier
plan où leurs noms dans les rayons des
librairies
rares sont ceux qui laissent une trace
dans la littérature quand on annonce on
donne toujours un petit air de la suite
des hommes d'état le témoignage sur la
vie politique de bruno le maire sera
publié en janvier
musique absolue lui est sélectionné pour
le prix du premier roman en attendant de
retrouver la petite musique de la
politique
bruno le maire gagnera peut-être la
reconnaissance de ses pairs en
littérature voilà bon reportage
d'alexandra colline aux frontières de la
littérature et de la politique l'a donc
vous vous situez désormais bruno le
maire perrine tarneaud bonsoir mr
effectivement vous n'avez pas obtenu les
parrainages des militants de l'ump nous
aurait peut-être le prix du premier
roman ce autant de valeur à vos yeux
ça a beaucoup de valeur oui je le cache
pas et je cache pas que cet engagement
littéraire c'est pas pour faire bien
c'est pas un témoignage en passant comme
le dit très bien michel crépu c'est
quelque chose que je fais depuis des
années des années et ça participe de ma
vie politique je conçois pas la vie
politique sans l'écriture sans la
narration qui de vie politique
les deux ambitions sont indissociables
oui c'est pas vraiment des ambitions
c'est le même goût de la vérité le même
goût de défendre un certain nombre de
convictions de dire quel est le monde
dans lequel on va vieillir
quel monde que l'on défend et je trouve
que la littérature est un des meilleurs
moyens de le faire comprendre aux autres
de le faire partager aux autres la
parole politique elle suffit pas d'abord
parce qu'elle est très souvent
déconsidéré et ensuite parce qu'on a
besoin d'une parole plus le personnel
plus authentique et cette parole là vous
la trouvez dans l'écriture beaucoup plus
que l'on la vie politique quotidienne
c'est ce que vous avez envie de faire
passer
dans votre prochain livre qui paraîtra
je crois en janvier toujours chez
gallimard c'est un peu la suite d homme
d'état que vous aviez écrit sur votre
expérience auprès de dominique de
villepin
là vous allez revenir sur les 18
derniers mois de la présidence de
nicolas sarkozy sous forme de quoi de
deux témoignages vous avec des
révélations et toujours des révélations
puisque forcément qu'on vous avez été
ministre vous avez vu vous avez entendu
des choses que d'autres n'ont pas
entendu mais c'est le même principe que
les hommes d'état c'est à dire un récit
au jour le jour sans doute plus dense
sans doute plus fouillée sans doute avec
plus d'informations parce que quand vous
êtes ministre une fois encore vous avez
accès des informations et à une vérité
que d'autres ne voient pas en cherchant
vraiment à expliquer ce que c'est que
d'être ministre
comment ça se passe quelles sont les
contraintes quelles sont les difficultés
auxquelles vous heurtez qu'est ce que ça
représente d'être chargé du g20 agricole
comme l'avait demandé le présent la
république
quelle est la relation entre un ministre
et le président de la république parce
que j'ai vu des foules de choses
totalement inexacts sur le sujet moi
j'ai bien travaillé avec nicolas sarkozy
et on le verra
très concrètement dans ce livre là et on
verra aussi ce que c'est que la ville un
président de la république sont
détaillés nostalgique
non c'est des pages qui disent voilà il
ya une vérité de la vie politique
et cette vérité la vie politique je
pense que dans un moment où la parole
politique est tellement déconsidérer où
les citoyens sont tellement circonspect
sur le responsable politique tellement
critique moi je veux leur dire vous
savez la plupart de ceux qui font la
politique ils sont engagés avec tout
leur coeur et tous leurs convictions et
vous allez voir effectivement avec ce
livre ce que c'est que d'être ministre
comment ça se passe quel est votre
engagement au quotidien comment vous
travaillez avec un président de la
république et vous verrez qu'il y avait
beaucoup de choses qui étaient sans
doute inexactes beaucoup de choses qui
n'ont pas été vues donc il y aura des
informations importantes
nicolas sarkozy occupe déjà une place
importante dans des hommes d'état est ce
que là il devient l'acteur principal de
ce nouveau livre à paraître
c'est normal quand vous faites le récit
des 18 derniers mois d'un quinquennat
que l'acteur principal
ce soit le président de la république et
le ministre qui l'asservît qui et qui
fait un bon personnage
delisle a en tout cas il a un côté
personnages de romans contrairement à
d'autres c'est pas un personnage
ordinaire c'est pas un personnage normal
c'est effectivement aussi un personnage
de roman et se livre sans ménager
parfois les critiques les reproches des
doutes sur certains choix qui ont été
faits rendra aussi hommage à la
dimension d'homme d'état de nicolas
sarkozy
vous avez parlé de notre projet qu'elle
je lui en ai parlé qu'est ce qu'il en
dit ils ont dit que il sait ce que
j'écris mon salaire mais s'y opposent
pas il vous laisse toute liberté
ce qu'il manque une dimension aux hommes
politiques qui n'écrivent pas à moi je
crois que ça fait partie des grandes
traditions françaises ce qui se dit et
redit oubliant de ceux complètement
perdu et je le regrette parce que la
france
oui mais la france n'a jamais été aussi
grande que lorsque politique et culture
que ce soit en littérature autre chose
ont été étroitement mêlés la france et
de langues la france une culture et plus
vous défendez cette langue plus vous
défendez cette culture plus la grandeur
de la france est défendu est-ce que
l'écriture ce peut être aussi un moyen
de fuir parfois la politique
oui c'est une manière aussi différente
de celle de la résistance
ceci d'une manière de reconsidérer les
choses avec un peu d'humour
vous savez c'est tellement violent la
vie politique
prendre un peu de distance et voir aussi
les aspects drôle comique humoristique
de cette vie politique c'est pas
forcément idiot
regardez cette bande dessinée est
absolument formidable qui a été écrit
par un de mes meilleurs amis qui
s'appelle quai d'orsay moi j'ai
travaillé l'ennemi de villepin je sais
ce que c'est que d'avoir écrit les
discours pour dominique de villepin
et je peux vous dire que cette bd a une
capacité à transformer tout ça et à
montrer l'aspect irrésistiblement
comique de certaines situations qui
allège un peu le poids du pouvoir
d'autant mieux dans musique absolu vous
raconter un petit peu la vie de carlos
kleiber et vous montrez ce musicien cet
artiste qui est rongé par le doute face
pas tellement le cas des politiques non
je crois pas je crois que beaucoup de
politiques sont rongés par le doute et
j'ai fréquenté beaucoup de politiques
des niveaux très élevés et j'ai toujours
trouvé notamment chez les responsables
politiques les plus importants un
mélange de très grande détermination à
défendre leurs convictions et en même
temps de
ce quand vous prenez des décisions aussi
difficiles que de libérer des otages que
d'employer la force armée en afghanistan
ou ailleurs ou d'intervenir dans des
banlieues difficiles ou de prendre même
des décisions d'augmentation des impôts
qui vont toucher des millions de ménages
en france
vous savez que vous prenez un risque
c'est toujours un pari n'y a pas de
certitudes en politique c'est un pari
qui est fait sur la base de vos
convictions est ce que vous croyez être
juste mais n'y a pas de certitude
moi je connais pas deux camps politiques
qui sont pas habité par le doute vous
même quand vous êtes lancés dans cette
campagne à la présidence de l'ump est ce
que vous étiez seulement mû par une
ambition personnelle qu'est ce que ça
vous a rapporté
je suis lancée parce que j'avais des
idées à défendre et que je fais un
diagnostic sur la situation de la droite
en france qui est un diagnostic sévère
je pense contrairement à certains mais
chacun est libre d'avoir son
appréciation que nous n'avons pas perdu
en 2012
nous avons perdu depuis des années
élections locales par action locale on a
perdu le pouvoir par les territoires par
les petites villes par les
agglomérations par les cantons et donc
si on veut vraiment récupérer le pouvoir
en france
il s'agit pas de se présenter en 2017
avec un très bon candidat appuyé les
français vont nous soutenir et aider à
notre candidat la présence de
républiques non il faut gagner
modestement humblement territoire par
territoire en reconquérant les
territoires locaux en france
est ce un jeu l'entente assez peu donc
moi je veux défendre ces idées là je
veux porter ce renouveau là est-ce que
ça m'a apporté justement c'est que vous
bien des courants qu'est ce que vous
avez
qu'est ce que ça fait c'est de
rencontrer des milliers de militants
partout en france que ce soit à béziers
et sélestat ou à douarnenez dans le
finistère des gens qui se disent le
message que vous portez c'est important
continuer alors vous êtes partie sale et
vous êtes fait un réseau je suis parti
seul un réseau c'est pas le bon terme
j'ai retrouvé à la fin réseau de 1000
idées aussi quand même des soutiens qui
vous disent voilà faut y aller moi
j'étais très touchée quand je me suis
lancé la campagne par la réaction des
sénateurs ici au sénat qui sont venus me
voir et qui m'ont dit mais tu ont
approché la bonne il faut pas que tu
lâches
je crois que vous êtes parti ça mais
vous êtes fait un réseau alors d'aigus
j'aime tellement le cas malheureusement
politique ça compte en politique des
gens qui me soutiennent
plus qu'un réseau on a vu que jean
françois copé avait été quand même
touché il a accusé le coup hier après le
ralliement de françois bayrou de
françois baroin à françois fillon
finalement c'est insensible jean
françois copé c'est quelqu'un qui est un
effectif ça c'est sûr donc je sais qu'il
a été touché
voilà c'est aussi la vie politique et
moi je respecte toujours la liberté de
choix de chacun je garde de très bonnes
relations avec chacun des membres de ce
groupe des mousquetaires qui n'existe
nerfs j'ai vu valérie pécresse encore
récemment je trouve que c'est une fille
qui a énormément de talent le mans de
qualité je travaille régulièrement avec
christian jacob j'ai vu françois baroin
n'est pas très longtemps
luc chatel même chose donc je garde
vraiment très bonnes relations et j'ai
eu l'occasion d'expliquer aussi ma
position à jean françois copé je l' ai
vu longuement aujourd'hui je lui ai dit
voilà je défend des idées je défends
sieste une doctrine politique est donc
respectée ou se demander quand est-ce
vector aux loisirs
ce chemin oui mais respectons le chemin
de chacun ma liberté c'est de dire il
faut du renouveau
il faut des idées des têtes pourraient
ne pas respecter cela comprend votre
démarche est ce qui comprend le fait que
vous ayez envie de rester neutre dans
cette campagne c'est quelqu'un que je
connais depuis longtemps et qui est
intelligent et ouvert
donc il comprend parfaitement les
démarches de chacun j'ai envie de vous
parler du qatar il ya des interrogations
à droite sur les projets
d'investissement en france du qatar vous
soutenez la demande d'une commission
denquête de lionnel luca pour savoir à
quoi vont servir en france et notamment
dans les banlieues
ces fonds mais est-ce que ce pas
pourtant pendant le quinquennat de
nicolas sarkozy que ce sens resserrer
les liens entre la france et le qatar
ça fait longtemps qu'il ya des liens
étroits entre la france et le qatar et
moi ces liens étroits ne me pose aucune
difficulté au contraire je trouve que
c'est une très bonne chose qu'il y ait
des liens importants entre deux pays qui
veulent travailler ensemble ensuite vous
avez un état le qatar qui décide de
faire des investissements massifs en
france dans tous les domaines que ce
soit le sport que ce soit la culture que
ce soit maintenant les quartiers
moi je n'accepte pas qu'il puisse y
avoir des investissements aussi
important dans des domaines aussi divers
parfois très sensibles comme les
quartiers les banlieues de certaines
agglomérations
sans qu'il y ait un minimum de
transparence chez moi j'ai pas peur de
quoi que ce soit je veux juste la
transparence je veux juste savoir quels
sont les objectifs du qatar quelle est
la stratégie du qatar à quel intérêt
serbie et pourquoi une puissance
étrangère respectable je n'ai rien
contre le qatar c'est que je respecte et
que je connais je veux juste savoir on
sait que il a détecté c'est pas d'un
coup de gaz arrivant je m'adresse aux
adultes les intérêts des cadres un jour
politique je ne place pas du tout par
rapport à un dominique de villepin ou
par rapport à qui que ce soit je me
place par rapport aux intérêts nationaux
je pose un problème de principe je
trouve qu'il y a un problème de principe
avoir une puissance étrangère quelle
qu'elle soit qui investit dans nos
quartiers sans que nous connaissions la
destination des fonds sans que nous
connaissions les raisons mais les
motiver quand on a l'impression que
l'argent est bon quand il va vers le cac
40 n'est pas bon quand il va vers les
branches socialise les élus ump se
demander à ses fins dans les quartiers
j'aimerais savoir quelle est la
stratégie du qatar dont je soutiens
effectivement cette commission denquête
je pense que c'est important d'avoir la
transparence et ça pourrait être
n'importe quel autre état de la planète
ce pourrait être des états unis la chine
l'inde je poserai exactement les mêmes
questions c'est pas le qatar en tant que
tels que je vise
je dis simplement que les élus du peuple
français ont droit de savoir pourquoi un
état étranger intervient financièrement
de manière aussi massive dans le domaine
culturel dans le domaine sportif et dans
le domaine social français ni plus ni
norman et que je veux pas et dans le
domaine économique à d'autres je ne veux
pas de polémique
les investissements étrangers sont les
bienvenus en france on en a besoin
je veux juste des explications et de la
transparence très bien merci
toute dernière question puisqu'il nous
reste 30 secondes en tant qu'ancien
ministre d'agriculture qu'avez vous
pensé du rapport du professeur séralini
sur les ogm
très alarmiste il les controversés
aujourd'hui par par des scientifiques
vous estimez cogestion on a droit à la
transparence absolue sur un sujet aussi
sensible
simplement la transparence c'est pas
balancer des rapports qui ont été
réalisés dans des conditions que les
scientifiques eux mêmes juges douteuses
au risque d'alarmer
concitoyens et les consommateurs la
transparence totale oui mais pas
d'alarmisme non plus merci et la semaine
prochaine ce sera jean françois copé
notre invité à preuve par 3 merci
monsieur le maire merci périment pas
très vite